[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster i'm konstantine kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
guests our brilliant guests this week
are Frances Foster hello introduce me
you and Constantine kissing indeed that
is the guests so a lot of you have been
asking for us to interview each other
and this is it now our show slogan used
to be we don't pretend to be the experts
we ask the experts and for that very
reason Francis is going to interview me
first okay here we go so I guess the
first question is what's your background
where did you come from well I think
most of our viewers know where I come
from at this point since we bring it up
every episode and they also know that
your money as well you have a list
opened into it a little bit watch it
what was your history growing up what
was it like growing up in the Soviet
Union yeah it was a crazy time because
the Soviet Union was this very stable
place seemingly the collapsed overnight
and I kind of was growing up my early
formative years were very much around
that so we went from this very stable
communist society to overnight to this
rampant capitalist society and it was an
interesting it was just an interesting
thing to observe more than anything as a
boy all of that happening was a very
tumultuous time and I you know obviously
growing up in the Soviet Union and
knowing the history of my family many of
whom were persecuted and sent to the
gulag for having the wrong opinion you
know that informs a lot of my views and
thoughts about what seems to be
happening in the West right now and what
was it like at that moment where the
Soviet Union because always find this
very interesting the society changed
like you said almost overnight how did
it change was it little things that you
noticed or was it everything different
when you woke up one day yeah I think
what it revealed is a lot of like the
things that we take for granted like
stability and people behaving in a
certain way and people being decent and
honest and all of that evaporated
overnight it was every man for himself
and I think it just highlighted to me
just the fact that we take a lot for
granted and it can collapse and it can
stop being the way that we're used to I
think most people in this country
probably I would imagine and I meet to
some extent as well we think you know
our prosperity democracy our freedoms
they're all Givens right which is one of
the reasons I am concerned about what
seems to be happening with the extremes
of politics emerging is that they don't
the particularly on the Left they don't
seem to realize that if you start
messing with the basic formula then
those things will go right so if you
start shutting down freedom of speech
that doesn't just have an impact on
freedom of speech has an impact on
democracy and democracy has an impact on
prosperity and then all of a sudden you
find yourself in a position where if you
overthrow what you have the place you
end up could be very very different and
and a lot worse than where you have
well we've touched on freedom of speech
so let's delve a little bit into that so
there's a lot of people I imagine people
on the far left who would say that
actually there is no problem with
freedom of speech what freedom the
people who say there's a problem with
freedom of speech or essentially either
incredibly cynical and looking to coin
in on it or make money out of it I
should say
or number two just shallow minded races
who want to hold racial epithets well
made obviously I want to be able to call
black people then word I mean that's
that's what my five for free speech is
all about obviously it's just like all
of us look the problem with the reason
that I oppose the work movement in
general is that they want to destroy
what I believe are the founding
principles of Western civilization right
and I'm allowed to say this because I'm
an immigrant
I think Western civilization is the best
so identify you as problematic I'm a
problematic Brit it's good to be one of
you finally yeah I just need to develop
a racist voice like you yeah exactly you
know it's it's it's got its it's got its
advantages having a racist voice yeah
like we are like I woke walk into a woke
comedy club ergo the fingers with
immigrants everybody leaves they've got
the place to myself do my emails yeah
anyway carry on so just like every other
gig you do as well yeah so fundamentally
Western civilization is built on a few
basic things right freedom democracy and
rationality and science right without
those things you would not have what we
have today okay now the work movement
essentially seeks to undermine and
destroy all of those so they seek to
destroy freedom how by destroying
freedom of speech right
why is freedom of speech important to
freedom in general what without the
freedom to think right you can't have
the free society that we have and if you
can't speak you can't think now the
other problem is if when you shut down
if I shut down your freedom to speak
that means I'm also shutting down my own
freedom to listen right and one of the
ways we learn and we have a cohesive
Society is the ability to communicate
with each other so freedom of speech
also has a flipside which is the freedom
to listen to people with other ideas
right if you shut all of that down your
other freedoms go out of the window
which is where we come unto democracy
you cannot have a democracy without a
plurality of opinions you know there was
a guy in the Russian parliament at some
point he said Parliament is no place for
debate right so that's the mentality in
authoritarian countries right so if you
can't have a plurality of opinions as we
try to do on the show and as we try to
encourage by having the show the way it
is you actually don't have democracy
right and that's another underpinning
principle of what the great things that
we have in this country and in the rest
of the West
and finally our prosperity is based to a
very large extent on science and
rationality right we would not be as
prosperous as wealthy as comfortable as
we are today if we did not have the
scientific progress that we've had right
scientific progress is based on freedom
it's based on the freedom to pursue the
the goals of research that you have I
mean we've had a number of social
scientists on the show who are no longer
able to do that who are fearful that if
they pursue the wrong research they're
going to be ostracized I mean Noah Karl
is a very good example of this right so
without the freedom of research you
don't have rational scientific progress
and without that you don't have the
prosperity that we have so the reason I
oppose the work movement is not that I
want to shout obscenities obscenities at
people it's that it's at an attempt
deliberate or not I don't know too
destroy everything that makes this
country great and I don't want that I
didn't come here for to see that happen
and it's interesting you say that and so
for instance people would say like
there's no problem with freedom of
speech but you came out in favor of not
deployment platform and Katie Hopkins
not removing her twitter account which i
think is still being removed out of
today by my powerful your powerful voice
what do you say to those people who say
look YouTube Twitter Facebook all of
these their private platforms are owned
by private companies they are free to do
as they please and they're free to
platform who they want and actually
removing someone's account is not an
issue with freedom of speech
at all well you see the thing there is
that actually it's funny that a lot of
people on the Left say that while
they're also massively in favor of
nationalizing things yeah I mean
essentially Facebook YouTube all these
other social media platforms Twitter etc
they have privately nationalized if you
like they've taken complete control of
what used to be the public square right
and that there are several problems with
that one of them is of course the
restriction of people like us we've had
videos taken down for hate speech and
then reinstated later but the other
problem with it is that what happens is
the way I think about it is essentially
you had a public square where people
would come and talk right and what these
companies have done very very well very
successfully is they've opened like a
little Starbucks off the public square
and they've said look why would you have
your conversation in a public square
where it's cold it's money it's you know
that you're out there in the elements
come inside have a nice social justice
Frappuccino right just sit here and
enjoy and talk in here and they've
created a great place for people to come
right so then everybody comes into this
little social justice Starbucks and
we're all suddenly finding that that's
the new public square yeah and once
that's happened they go okay now we have
a bunch of rules about what you are not
allowed to say right and what that does
is first of all obviously marginalizes
people who have non-conforming opinions
which again is counter to the principles
of Western civilization but what it also
doesn't this is very dangerous very very
dangerous and I'm concerned about the
rise of the far right as I am about the
far
it drives people with genuinely
problematic opinions into their own
little beer sellers that they start to
open up so the eight Chan's and the four
turns of the world where essentially
it's only people who have problematic
opinions instead of having those
opinions ventilated to challenge debated
and having reasonable people like us
going well this is too far you know they
just marinate in their own insanity in
these places and that's the other
problem is if you push these people out
into their own little space they end up
radicalizing themselves they self
radicalized and a lot of the problems
that you see you know as you know as you
and I know you know men are being
demonized in society but there's also a
counter movement to that which is these
women hating genuinely toxic unpleasant
basement-dwelling
in cells it's a bit harsh the London
open you 'only hate women yeah you know
and you know if they experience this
online when we've we've gone to
different places to look at you know
where should we post our content there
are some groups that I talk about the
problems with feminism which are very
reasonable
there are other places that just
literally full of misogyny right and the
reason for that is that these people are
being driven into their own little echo
chamber by being excluded from the main
conversation if they had their
problematic opinions out there in the
public square they would have people
that they like and respect sometimes
challenging their own opinions you know
it's like one fans of our show watch us
and they come some someone mentioned
some weird conspiracy and we got come on
I don't think that's true that actually
has the potential to change people's
opinions about things which is why it's
important for that conversation to be
had so I I don't agree at all with this
idea that they're just private companies
they're not they've privatized they've
nationalized essentially that the public
square into private ownership by one
group and and that's that's dangerous
and a problem we we we need to find a
way of dealing with that whether that's
you know a First Amendment for the
Internet of some kind or whether it's
breaking those companies up and it's
interesting that you say that and we
were talking I remember count danker the
can't Bank no interview we did which was
all
a year ago now yeah and if you haven't
seen it or listen to it check it out
it's brilliant and he said something but
I found quite poignant in it's it's
almost we don't believe in forgiveness
anymore
hmm I think we've now got this attitude
where if somebody does something wrong
we immediately cancel them despite who
it may be despite you know everything
that they've done and you know their
whole history or whatever else they've
done this one thing no matter how
trivial and then that seems to be over
for them yeah I'm also concerned about
the unfair criticism of Jimmy Savile and
a great friend of the royal family but
anyway so we've seen that you didn't
there's a problem with forgiveness in
society at the moment yeah I do
I do think there is a problem and and
the thing that probably worries me even
more than that is just how quickly the
norms of society are changing to the
point where you don't really know what
is tolerant tolerable or acceptable
anymore so I posted a Twitter clip of
Robin Williams on my Twitter last night
of him doing jokes about Barack Obama
this was 12 years ago 12 years is not a
long time
yeah and he's he's talking about how
Barack Obama is a very eloquent man but
I know a lot of people were expecting
him to kind of essentially were saying
to black it up at the inauguration and
he does like this whole black accent and
let me introduce you to my political
posse this is a little ray ray and Colin
Powell who is bad to the bone right and
you would you know talks about how were
they're gonna open up a basketball court
in the Rose Garden right that was 12
years ago and that was one of the most
beloved comedians in the history of
comedy right if a comedian did that on
stage today 12 years later I mean it's
over oh yeah absolutely
game over done yeah you're done yeah now
if that is the extent to which these
things can change in this short period
of time what it leaves a lot of people
with is well I don't even know what what
the right thing is anymore we were kind
of in this limbo a good example of this
is you know I think I might have
mentioned that previously my wife and I
over Christmas we tend to watch a lot of
movies to spend some time together maybe
watch like a die-hard
kind of Christmas kind of thing and
we're watching one of the die-hard
movies and there's this moment in it
which is just blew my mind where there's
a black woman who who's managing the
telephone calls for like a police
department and due to some kind of
emergency she's forced to manage the
phone calls for a whole city and when
her supervisor comes in and tells her
this she says if you think that's gonna
happen you think I'm gonna marry Donald
Trump right
a black woman using Donald Trump as an
aspirational figure saying you know this
is like the most the thing that in my
imagination would be the best thing ever
he said Melania is black she's gonna
just intruder herself so the norms of
society have changed dramatically our
expectations of what is and isn't racist
have changed dramatically so what you
find yourself is the examples like
Alister Stewart right who sent a poem to
somebody a white person and then a black
person and he simply never occurred to
him that people would choose to
interpret some words in the shakespeare
poem as racist but the society is moved
on so quickly that he even hasn't had a
chance to catch up to it
so even if you accept that these norms
are good and right which I don't but
even if you accept them
the pace of which this progressivism is
advancing is makes it almost impossible
for anyone to actually understand what
the right think the socially correct
thing is anymore
and of course we've completely redefined
all the meanings of all these words you
know racism doesn't mean what race is
used to mean racism used to mean being
prejudiced against somebody on the basis
of their skin color
now racism means that you were
insensitive to something that you're
supposed to have anticipated about how
your words could be misinterpreted
right so you said it yourself I think to
me the other day racism that means you
said something that could be
misinterpreted that's what that's what
that's where we are these words are
quoted out of context yeah but you're
right yeah yeah yeah and that's
essentially what where we are and I mean
it's it's not a particularly pleasant
question to us because it's sort of an
impossible question to answer
but how do you see the landscape panning
out within the next few years so you
think that we've sort of heat as Rawdon
little would say peak wank or do you
think things are gonna get worse before
they get better or they are just gonna
keep getting worse I think it's it's
impossible to say isn't it
I was very optimistic at the beginning
of the year with the election of the
Conservative Party
not because I necessarily think that you
know we should have a Conservative Party
in government forever but I just thought
that that was such a blow back against
this world culture that people will be
forced to wake up I don't think that's
happened I don't see that happening and
if you look at you know the Prime
Minister is making very conciliatory
noises and always saying he's definitely
not going further to the right you know
he's trying to keep the middle together
despite all of that people are still
reacting as if you know we've got a
fascist and in in 10 Downing Street so I
do think it looks like it will get worse
before it gets better but what I'm
deeply encouraged by is there's a
counterculture emerging I think we're
part of that comedy Unleashed as part of
that that there are people who are
starting to wake up to the fact that the
way that they've been told is the right
way to think isn't actually the way that
most people think and I'm very proud of
the fact that we've created a platform
where people with the countering ideas -
that can come on you know zoobi Lawrence
Fox a bunch of other people who who now
have a voice in society which is
prominent and powerful we were the first
people to ever do a long term long-form
interview with them yeah about these
issues I'm very proud of that I think
it's important that we do that because
my fundamental goal with trigonometry is
to bring people together and the only
way you can bring people together is if
you actually have honest conversations
and allow people to say what they think
Anton you're meant to unfold the Nazi
banner when he was saying his home phone
annoyed dogs and uber alles was gonna
play
so it's interesting let's talk about
comedy because we're both comedians
not everyone agrees how do you see the
comedy landscape at the moment do you
think it's we're in a healthy place
comedic ly or do you think the comedy is
fundamentally biased and well that's
it's not comedy the commercial leading
[ __ ] question yeah there yeah the
comedy industry is biased I think comedy
soup is biased will always be biased
it's just the nature I mean all the
psychological research shows that you
know people who are kind of more
conservative leaning tend to go into
kind of managerial professions the law
things like that because they pay
exactly and liberal a more kind of
open-minded Meeropol open-mindedness as
a trait psychologically not as a value
judgment tend to go into the liberal
professions the arts comedy etcetera so
comedy will always have that slant the
question is how does the comedy industry
treat people who don't fall into that
because it's perfectly possible for the
comedy industry to be full of people who
are progressive on the Left if you like
or this kind of new left but for those
people to be actually open-minded and
say well it's great though you know
we've got the Jeff Noah codes and the
Simon Evans and the you know Dominick
frisbees and Alistair Williams
and Andrew Lawrence's and the Francis
Foster and the constant in kitchens of
the world right if that were the case
I'd have no problem with the fact that
more open-minded liberal people go into
comedy the problem for me seems to be
that those people are incredibly narrow
minded they incredibly close minded they
don't want people with a different
opinion and they see them as bad and
wrong and evil that to me is the problem
but I equally that you know I always say
to people you know you know but talking
$200 people like that who who are
concerned about to stay off comedy and
all that kind of things that though all
the people that you respect in the
history of comedy
they always pushed against the grain all
of them oh absolutely I mean my favorite
of people who sort of parrot the liberal
consensus and you know it's fair enough
that you can see you support it but you
know it when you seem to support every
aspect of it you start to think well
you're not entirely thinking for
yourself but then they they say that
they love Patrice O'Neal I mean a
Patrice
Neal was alive today his career would
last about six and a half minutes yeah
before that there you know he got shut
down but it's an important point you
make because ultimately if you want to
be a comedian and you want to be an
interesting committee and you want to be
someone who people talk about then
you've got to piss a few people off and
I don't even see it as pissing people
off I mean for me the goal is whenever I
go on stage and you know I just saw me
try some new material about why I
respect Donald Trump right it's not
because I actually respect Donald Trump
necessarily yeah really do they like
some bits yeah they didn't like some
bits but who's that moment where you
said that the collective tightening of
our toes was a thing to behold but
that's exactly what I'm trying to do
every time I go and state because I want
those ice [ __ ] to tighten and then
to use logic and humor to unlock the
[ __ ]
I really wanted you to say the words
logics and facts yeah no but I mean to
me that's really the the greatest comedy
is when someone says something abhorrent
yeah and then logically proves why it's
funny to say that yeah that to me is the
you know Bill burr is a master of this
of course you know that that to me is
the goal if you like so I my goal is
when I go on stage is to say something
that shocks people and then make a joke
that forces them to laugh yeah that's
what I want yeah so and that will always
be a harder path because it's much
easier to write a joke about how but
Donald Trump's orange and Boris is fat
and whatever yeah but never interested
me no no it's not it's the challenge I
think comes with that type of comedy
it's like you said trying to get people
laughed it despite themselves and Trump
is become a hack topic even though deep
down I don't believe there are any hack
topics in comedy only hack approaches
and actually getting somebody to laugh
about Trump even though that they might
profess to hate him because there's so
many parts of Trump that we don't
acknowledge he's gonna win again isn't
it yeah I was absolutely going win again
he's gonna win again and again I hope
that will be a wake-up moment because
look this is a thing that we get asked
very often and you
conservative-leaning people who like us
now start to call us conservative
neither of us is conservative I would
identify it to socially conservative you
are you're straight way and racist no I
know what you mean but you are not a
supporter of the conservative and I am
politically very much in the center
I am certainly socially conservative on
some things I'm very very social liberal
and other things and I can't remember
how we got into this now conversation
but we're talking about Trump
yeah and whether he's gonna get elected
or so my point is Donald Trump is not a
natural politician who I have a lot of
affinity with I don't I would not in a
if you gave me a field of candidates
from the far right to the far left and
Donald Trump was one of them he would
not be who I picked I'd want someone
much further to the right obviously he
it's interesting when people criticize
him he's not actually that far to the
right of course and he's very funny as
well but she's quite yeah he's very
funny
yes but my point is I would want someone
who is a centrist Democrat if you like
or a very centrist Republican somewhere
within that center field right that's my
natural instinct and I don't genuinely
approve of politicians who are
outlandish who are inconsiderate with
their language who offend lots of people
I'm not naturally drawn to that but in
in the social space that we have now if
you give me the choice between Hillary
Clinton or you know the the work Brigade
on the current Democratic Left and
Donald Trump it's a binary choice and
the problems on the Left are so great
that you you're forcing me to go in that
other direction you know not because I
like Donald Trump but because that those
are the only two options you know and
and it's you know as you know I voted
for the Conservatives for the first time
in my life at the last election it's the
same thing I mean I look here and this
is kind of where we I just interrupt you
didn't put a cross did you put little
swastika it's exactly what I do David
with the swastika yes so and that's
because I mean this is other thing we've
lost is the ability to distinguish
between
liking somebody and acknowledging their
competence Boris Johnson ran an
incredibly effective campaign
Dominic Cummings his principal advisor
I've read some of his blog posts that
guy's intelligent as [ __ ] he's
intelligent incredibly intelligent
Donald Trump say we wonder about him
he's been incredibly effective in what I
watch his State of the Union I mean it
wasn't the way it's normally done but as
a reality TV show it was incredibly
powerful yeah and all those stories and
all that stuff so these people are good
at what they do right and the problem
for the other side is where's the
competence where other people who are
actually good at being politicians who
will bring the country together and as
long as there's no one like that well
they're never gonna get elected and I'm
not gonna vote for someone who I think
is an idiot you know so that that's the
problem so you remember the yang Kang
yeah absolutely but it doesn't look like
the yang is gonna get elected so who do
you think will do it looks like people
did she's doing well at the moment I
mean as we record this anyway who knows
man it's it's all up for grabs Joe Biden
Donald Trump as well yeah a battle of
the grabbers yeah
well he's more of a hair sniffer his
name Biden is yeah he likes to get off
yeah yeah thanks for bringing me
everyone needs a hoppy mic yeah exactly
so yeah I don't know I don't know who's
gonna win but I if it's Buddha Chaz
Elizabeth Warren I mean they're all so
far to the left I just don't see anyone
going for that and as I say the only
positive that can come out of that is
they get a wake-up call and you know in
history every action has an equal and
opposite reaction so the moment someone
with veers are far far to the left or to
the right eventually there's there's a
counter-narrative that comes out and you
know tony blair was a good example of
this in in in the 90s you know people
were tired of the conservative
government but they also didn't want a
socialist in power so along comes
someone who's more of centrist and he
can
kind of bring the country together for a
bit when people forget about blend the
Conservative Party is that that
electron's very very unusual because it
was a landslide but also the
Conservatives left a country that
economically was in very very healthy
yeah so that when Blair took over
actually you know the country was in a
pretty good state yeah yeah
and we'll see well so we'll see what
happens in 2020 but as I say I hope
people start now to wake up to the
realization that going far off the deep
end saying that you know controlling
immigration is racist and all this other
[ __ ]
that's a wake up call people start to
realize we need to talk honestly and
openly about these issues instead of
shutting them down I still think you're
drinking Christmas sherry if III Lord
your optimism but I don't think it's
gonna happen
hmm all right well what about you my
friend tell us a little bit about who
you are and what's your background
right okay so I was born and brought up
in South London my mother is from
Venezuela everybody who listens to the
truth of the pod have a drink have a
drink have a drink have a shot whatever
it may be so my mom grew up very very
wealthy in Venezuela she was from a very
wealthy background from a great
privilege wealth and status and all the
rest of it
in 1999 Hugo Chavez was elected and one
of my relatives was actually present at
the Bank of Venezuela at that time so
and I think it was around 2003 2004
where Chavez demanded to my relative
that he essentially hand over all the
gold reserves to him and his family and
that he could distribute them in the way
he saw fit my other people no doubt yeah
of course and the people being his
family and my relatives said know that
god belongs to Venezuela it does not
belong to you I will not sanction that
Chavez went on TV and said the words the
UA Gore Luis Guerra
which means do it jag or least get out
my relative was M put under house arrest
until he gave up that gold all of
Venezuela's gold - Chavez what a [ __ ]
I'm sure all the keyboard warriors would
have done it here um if I was a naughty
Germany I would have shot him or myself
yeah and the reason I I always talk
about Venezuela is I need you to know
I'm not just a straight white male but
know that there's there's an important
reason because this is actually coming
out as gay no the reason I'm doing that
is because that has essentially informed
all of my thinking from essentially the
start of my adult life because when
Chavez came to power a lot of people
thought he was going to make a real
difference to Venezuela and initially he
did that it was going to be a new dorm
because before that there was a
government which was deeply corrupt as
most Latin American governments are and
it was also racist however what happened
with Chavez is that he then brought in
widespread socialism and then the
country became ever more corrupt and he
and him and Maduro turned a country
which was a fifth biggest all producer
in the world with the largest oil
reserves in the world into a country now
which has a larger migrant population
than Syria and has got inflation rates
of over something like a million percent
as one of our former guest said Vladimir
Hernandez make up a number regarding
inflation and in Venezuela and it's
probably higher than that to the point
where you go into a supermarket in
Venezuela and its are highly unlikely
that you'll find any goods and if you do
they don't attach prices to them because
by the end of the trading day they will
become obsolete I've also seen the way
that freedom of speech has been affected
my cousin who is a journalist in
Venezuela had to leave because in
Venezuela there is a secret police
called the Sabine and what they do is if
you were known to criticize the
government be openly critical of the
government write articles that are
criticizing the government they will
turn up at your flat at one o'clock in
the morning normally wearing ski masks
and the very punctual yeah they're very
unlike most Latin Americans
knock on the door and then you will
disappear if you'll be put in something
called an odd number which is not
difficult to guess what number is it
roughly translated it more accurately
translated it means the tomb
and you will disappear sometimes you
will come back sometimes you won't but
it's touching go as to what happens so
he fled the country I've had most of my
family now living in different countries
most similar in South America a couple
of months ago I was talking to my cousin
Johan who said that we have regular
electrical blackouts running water was
so toxic that you can't actually drink
the running water he drinks from a water
tank which is on his roof in his house
and people actually go and steal the
water from the water tank so that's
where Venezuela is at the moment it
calls to me a tremendous amount of pain
when I was 30 years old my grandfather
was murdered which is a murder that I
will never get justice for because the
it's a lawless state there's no police
it's it's that's where we are in
Venezuela and I've always been someone
who's been on the Left politically I see
myself as being on the left
I believe that ultimately the left
stands for reduction of inequality
between rich and poor
I believe the society especially in this
country because of the class system is
still very very unequal and it's
something I strew ly believe in however
I watched with horror and dismay as
korban essentially embraced the the and
supported the Chavez government them and
the Maduro government he refuses to
condemn them he refuses to speak out
against them The Guardian most lot
they're journalists support openly
supporting the Venezuelan government
people like going Jones talking about
how actually that it's it's a forceful
for good in the world despite the fact
that journalists were disappearing or
having to leave and it made me
incredibly worried because if you have
those people in power there are people
who a do not respect the rule of law and
be they do not respect freedom of speech
and I saw that Labor Party is being
dangerous fundamentally deeply dangerous
and I hear people talking about
socialism on the left
and after having seen what's happened in
Venezuela go from a very very wealthy
country to a country where there is very
there's you know there's no toilet paper
there's no adding a bank and not even
upon his maize and that we've made you
make a dipper which is a staple diet of
every Venezuelan and there is none there
is none wherever you look and people
cannot afford to feed their children and
they talk about socialism I always think
that you do not know the forces that you
were messing with and I don't think they
do but do you think maybe they mean
something else when they talk about
sauce do you think it's just this utopia
in their heads that they imagine this
perfect world where man has been
improved and and we're now all perfect
and equal and blah blah blah
before I might have been more charitable
but but all of those people supported
Venezuela all of those people supported
Chavez government and then when it
turned sour they all walked away and
wash their hands which could be
understandable but essentially that is
my family and that is a country where I
spend a large part of my life in so you
your opinions and your actions have
consequences and I understand if you
support Chavez him them and then my
daughter and then renege alone on that
and go look I was wrong I was incorrect
that was a mistake on my part but they
seem to have no desire to and they still
peddling this socialist agenda and when
you have someone like a shot oh come on
good morning Britain and say the words I
am literally a communist and then people
tweeting about how that is somehow you
know worthwhile and Noble and something
that should be sure supported it I find
it quite frankly terrifying because
unless you grow up in that country
unless you have seen the evils of
socialism communism you really have no
idea of what the impact that has on the
society freedom of speech and the lives
of your relatives and the lives of
ordinary day-to-day people where people
feel so terrified that they can't speak
that they live their life in permanent
fear I'll give you an example a very
good friend of mine who has now had to
leave Venezuela he now lives in America
he came over and her to the UK and I
hadn't seen him in a long time and we
sat down and we had dinner
it was him myself my parents both my
parents a mid to late 70s now they're
elderly people and they've known Henry
since he was a baby and we were talking
and my dad said to him Henry could you
please speak up I can't hear what you're
saying and Henry said to him I'm very
sorry Jim
I was speak louder it's just in
Venezuela were so used to whispering and
I found that incredibly powerful living
in a country where you were used to
whispering and then living in the UK for
the last couple of years with Corbin and
seeing people going on TV saying I'm
literally a communist because to me that
is the ultimate goal of socialism and
communism is to make everybody the same
and how do you make everybody the same
you make everybody think the same and
how do you make everybody think the same
you destroy all opinions that are not
your opinion and it's it's terrifying
and I never thought I'd say this as
someone who has always been on the left
but I was happy when Johnson won and I'm
glad I didn't vote for them I voted SDP
which is a sort of left-wing socially
conservative party good old problematic
but that's where we are and I'm
hopefully so we're happy that Boris won
or were you happy the Labour lost I was
happy that they lost yeah that's what it
sounds like yeah I wasn't happy that
Boris won I think ultimately the if you
look at become what the Conservatives
have done over ten years which is
preside over austerity which has created
so much hardship you look we're filming
this in London anecdotally how many more
homeless people do it's unbelievable man
every time we walk to the tube station
here there's just tents everywhere yeah
and it wasn't like that before no I've
lived in this city all my life I grew up
here in the 80s when actually as a city
it wasn't as wealthy as it is now I
never used to see tents there were
homeless people but certainly not under
this number I mean I don't know and the
austerity is such a big tent thing so I
mean will soon be talking to Liam
Halligan about his new book about the
housing crisis that to me seems to be a
bipartisan issue yes right I'd I'm not
sure that the Conservatives are
necessarily cause that you know
I'm saying no no absolutely but I think
what is undeniable is that what the
Conservatives have done is it cuts to
local services cuts to local government
cuts to mental health services so for
instance my girlfriend works in mental
health and the cuts that she's facing as
you know as part of her job means that
unfortunately more and more children are
slipping through the cracks and not
getting the support they so desperately
ill then end up on the street mental
health is a huge factor in that yes and
it also what it doesn't acknowledge as
well as something I think was 45 or 50
percent of prisoners have a special need
yeah so it costs roughly thirty thousand
pounds a year to keep somebody in prison
but actually it's a very strong reason
to advocate for the death but the
uniquely rush in a project when actually
if we caught these people earlier and
gave them the necessary support it
wouldn't have the impact later on in
life so I don't agree with you know the
austerity I think there was certain you
know there's an argument economically
that we did need it but I think
proportionally it hurt a lot of the
weakest people and they wasn't done in a
fair wave yeah I don't think it was done
in a fair way that's probably something
I can agree with even though personally
I actually think we needed more
austerity from it from a broader yeah
I'll make perspective I mean the
indebtedness of this country on the
personal and national level is its
unfathomable yeah how much in debt we
are and we at some point someone's gonna
have to do something about it and it's
either going to be us or your
grandchildren yeah what do you want your
grandchildren probably yeah yeah but but
the thing is is well that is not just a
problem unique to this kind remember
when we spoke to Jim Rick oh oh yeah
absolutely
know it's a problem across the West
actually Russia uniquely has a surplus
does it it doesn't have a budget deficit
that's what happens when you get Putin
exactly massive gold reserves as well
really Jim would be very happy Jim has a
huge respect for Russia but but anyway
so you're kind of opposed but you know
one of the things that you often get
criticized for is people say oh you're
just this leftist kook yeah and I don't
I've never seen you that way understood
why I mean I think he was interesting on
the live stream the other day you said
that
you when we interviewed Sargon which was
over a year ago you were much more kind
of hesitant about some of those views
because you used to be a lot more work
yeah
do you feel that you've become less woke
as things change or is it more you've
become more vocal about what you
actually think I think it's a
combination of things I think it's a
clarification in my views I understand a
lot more about the subjects that we're
talking about you listen to people who
actually very informed about what
they're discussing and as a result of
that you can't help but formulating your
ideas I also think as well more and more
I think about this is with the European
Union
freedom of immigration no Blalock alike
as somebody who you know whose mom is a
first generation immigrant all the rest
of it um I don't think ultimately that
it works for a lot of people and I
understand why people do not want
freedom of immigration I think
immigration is healthy and is necessary
for a country I think open borders makes
it incredibly difficult to plan when you
don't know how many people are coming
into a particular country especially
when Mohsen will come to London
understandably so if I was an immigrant
you'd come here because of the jobs and
all the rest of it what's at the same
time having in a housing crisis how can
you plan for that you it's simply
impossible and I think more and more
I've become disillusioned with the left
because of just the name-calling you
know if you're a conservative person
whether economically or socially that
automatically makes you a bad person
there also no Matta means you're racist
you're stupid you're all these things
and it's it's simply not true it's
fascinating to me out of doing
trigonometry just how many people we've
met who have this terrible reputation
yeah who keep being called names by the
people that we share stages with every
night and then you meet this person and
you got this is like one of the nice
people you know yeah it's quite
incredible how people and and then when
you find yourself as you've done and
I've done in the newspapers or whatever
rocked with hit pieces and you go okay
nothing that's in the news generally is
true you know people being called and
smeared it's all [ __ ] for the most
part absolutely and this for instance my
voice right though which I found deeply
upsetting
vice wrote that article about me well
not about me it was about the Commodore
leeched but they started with you yeah
they started with me they knew they knew
I was coming and they said that it was a
far-right comedy night despite the fight
that the original emcee who had to drop
out because she had another gig is
really 'no who is a mixed race woman and
then you looked at the people who've
been on you know you've had to saudi or
asthma who is a muslim woman who wears a
hijab while she's on stage you've had
Dame Baptiste who is a black comic
you've heard his Shappy call sandy who's
headlined it who is an Iranian woman but
it doesn't matter that doesn't matter
because they have a narrative and you
know they have a narrative which they
adhere by we adhere to and facts don't
matter
and then this article was then retweeted
by lots of people and I was still a
teacher at that point I could have lost
my job I could have never have worked
again because I was a figurehead for
far-right comedy knowledge and my hand
my head teacher actually saw that
article but he was saying you know it's
nonsense and you know we're supporting
all the rest of it but that doesn't
matter to them it doesn't matter that I
could have lost my job that actually I
could do it doesn't matter that that's
what they want yeah yeah yeah that I
could have you know I could have been
banned from the teaching profession
because ultimately for the second time
because ultimately I'm a racist and by
appearing at comedy Unleashed I somehow
support the far-right let me you're
white you've got tattoos you wear Fred
Perry and polo shirts yeah let's be
honest yeah yeah except one plus one
equals 19 exactly so what do you so you
you think I'm drinking the Christmas
sherry in being somewhat hopeful that
people might start to wake up and
realize that this approach doesn't work
yeah do you not think that's going to
happen what do you think is gonna happen
I think that what happens is you're
going to be but ever more emboldened
ever more entrenched they're going to
just drill down into their ideas that
you know everyone who doesn't agree with
them a stupid racist and all the rest of
it I mean this has been best summed up
by Rebecca long Bailey who gave jeremy
corbyn's
leadership ten out of ten
well the worst election results in 1930
whatever it is losing all your major
heartlands or the vast majority of them
and that is 10 out of 10 leadership but
but this is the point I'm making
eventually someone is gonna go this
doesn't work someone is gonna come out
and go look we need to start winning
power again right right just as Tony
Blair did right just as David Cameron
was exactly the same thing he came out
after a period of Tory part you know
they went through the end Duncan Smith's
and the William Hague's and all these
people and eventually someone came along
who could bring the party together get
them to stop banging on about Europe for
a bit yeah right etc so all of this
always comes back to once you go far off
the deep end eventually the veil is
lifted from your eyes okay eventually
but I think it's going to be a really
really long time because look at all the
candidates that Labour have got at the
moment
what labour needs to do in order to win
and this is going to really upset a few
people on the left is they need to
accept that the most majority of this
country people in this country is racist
or socially conservative lift of centre
social conservatives and if you want to
capture those hearts and minds you have
to create policies that appeal to those
people but I don't think they're
interested so they would have to start
talking about family community crime
yone order immigration right all objects
services public services importance of
the family yeah right stable household
etc but all of these things are
problematic yeah right so like in
particularly immigration oh yeah I think
you you would not I can't think of one
leftist politician who would talk open
and honestly about immigration and
reduction of immigration and get
anywhere near power not just not just
right well anywhere near pal well I mean
Paul Emery made this point when I
pressed him on whether he would run for
office I mean Paul Embry in my opinion I
don't I don't know what the [ __ ] I'm
talking about but my opinion that I look
at him and I go this could be a future
prime minister yeah that's how that's
how I see him yeah and I could be wrong
about that I don't know how good he is
of managing people or his analytical
skills or whatever but
as a person presence as a presence you
go that is a guy that III don't agree
with a lot of his ik I mean he's a
socialist economically and that I just
look him and I go with that that's
that's a man that I respect right now
there are plenty of people like that but
as she said you know she's not gonna get
anywhere near being an MP or long Prime
Minister in the current Labor Party but
my point is at some point in the next
ten years somebody in the Labor Party is
gonna go is gonna have to go look we
want to win right so we need someone
like that so to actually you know
represent us that's going to happen it
has to does it yeah does it I don't I've
come to the point where the left where
they're more interested in being right
than winning
they've always been more interested in
being right than winning but what it
takes is someone like Tony Blair or
someone like that to come in and go you
know we've had a really bad run of this
let's get this [ __ ] together but then it
would mean them accepting that talking
about immigration and reduction you know
and reduction to the amount of people
coming into this country maybe having a
different system whatever it may be is
not racist and that's going to take a
long long long time and I don't see it
happening any time soon
and like I said let's go back to the
candidates yeah it's not gonna happen at
this election that's what about the next
election probably not as well we don't
know what will happen but yeah I mean I
take your point I think you're right it
will take some time it does look like
the Tories are gonna be in powerful for
another ten years it's gonna take and
then when you look at it over the good
of it you know that's done years in
power twenty years in power that is
quite impressive isn't it just how how
loony the left has become and and this
is and this is somebody who is on
talking to you somebody who's on the
center it's very worrying and it's even
if you were on the right it's still very
worrying because what this country needs
is a strong powerful well-led opposition
we don't have that we have no opposition
you're right I mean this is dangerous
this is this is what but that's why
immigration has become such an issue
because the labor government was very
powerful and had an incredibly weak and
divided opposition
and that's why they were able to
introduce these immigration policies
that just allowed more people to come
into this country as William clusen told
us in ten years then had come into this
country its entire history since 1066
yeah right and that was because there
was no strong opposition absolutely and
then you start to think to yourself more
and more if there is no strong
opposition to this conservative
government which there isn't they can
pretty they've got carte blanche to do
whatever they want this is why I'm not
happy about it to some extent about
what's happened because if you're on the
right you're celebrating right now you
know you're gonna be in power for a long
time your your values are going to be
implemented blah blah blah blah blah but
I like you believe that we need a strong
strong debate between the two sides
either which is what I think would do
the show right absolutely it's why we do
this show but you see it in when we're
trying to get people on guests on the
dearth of intellectually robust
left-wing fingers there's a dearth yeah
I'm really because I'm on the left and
we and we always try and balance a show
people you know got their own agenda and
say whatever they may say but we
genuinely do and there's been times we
sat down you got right okay present me
with guests from the left who you want
to listen to I come up with the same
seven or eight names yeah and that's it
and we've had half of them on the show
yeah we've had half of them on the show
and it's coming to the planet literally
you go from Paul Embry and then and then
it's like the ash soccers and that are
embossed anees yeah I mean there's a
caller yeah it would be great yeah we
would be great and we'd love to have
them on it would make a fantastic
episode but there's very few people
putting that reasonable debate using
logic without descending into hurling
epithets and all the rest of it and
screeching I'll be honest with you every
time I see people on the left in a
debate a large part of them I end up
having my head in my hands because
they're not interested in winning hearts
and minds now which means they're not
interested in winning an election and
that means ultimately that you were
always going to live in a country which
is being dominated by a right of center
or a right-wing government up the
Oh God every time I talk and where do
you think culturally we are as a country
do you think people are gonna on the
right maybe all the socially
conservative our society is now going to
kind of be emboldened by everything
that's happened I can see the culture
war deepening I think that the the the
work aspect of the left they have they
will have not they have no interest in
changing their views they ultimately
believe that what they think and say is
right they're not gonna change I my
worry is a society is going to become
ever more polarized that's what I really
worry about my and that ultimately we
are not going to be able to do what is
necessary for society to function which
is sit around a table listen to each
other share ideas and have a debate a
debate means to listen it's not about
winning it's not about destroying or all
of these even there may feel great click
or all of these you know things
ultimately is about ego it's about
listening it's about trying to improve
as a person and right now where we are I
find it incredibly boring
I mean how do you feel about I think it
was Rebecca Longdale if I'm not wrong
saying that she doesn't have any Tory
friends I think that is a sign of a
childish and immature person and
ultimately somebody who was incredibly a
liberal if you do not have friends who
have difference of opinion to you then
ultimately you or somebody who is not
there's not living a full life I'm an
atheist I have friends who from you who
who were religious I see myself now
actually as a socially conservative I
have friends who are very very liberal
because it's only by surrounding
yourself with people who have difference
of opinion to you do you ultimately grow
as a human being very good yeah yeah so
since we've done this how long do you
think it's going to take for us to get
cancelled again again yeah we're just
I'm at that point I think we're we're
just in the permanent state of good
cancellation yeah well I've kind of got
used to I don't even have to think about
it but yeah I always feel like there's
something around the corner where you
know where one misstep I mean so much
the fascinating thing to me is how
people don't understand irony yeah like
whenever we you and I make an ironic
joke like pretending to be sexist or
something for the purposes of a joke
half the people watching go oh it's
women and it's like so you and I as
comedians who do our thing publicly or
always I feel like one step away which
is why I just preempted now and I just
go I don't give a [ __ ]
you know about this whole thing but it's
crept into comedy that now I you can't
make a joke anymore well you can
obviously you can make a joke that's
gonna be missing - you can't make the
icon [ __ ] mikage no you making sure
but then you have to write two or three
jokes on the epithet and the lighting
and then pricking the bub the bubble of
outrage that is going to come from one
or two people and make a joke laughing
at them because that's where we are now
as a society yeah it's it's very
interesting yeah especially of times
worst of times to be a comedian yeah for
us and then with trigonometry is the
same I mean in some ways I almost feel
like the more successful trigonometry is
the more that's a symptom of a very
unhealthy society yeah because I mean
I've got to be honest you mate
the reality is it is deeply unhealthy
the two comedians are having to have
these conversations on YouTube instead
of the mainstream media doing it
properly but they just don't know just
done and and so the fact that we are
having a lot of success with this is
actually a sign of things really bad
it's you know it's my girlfriend made
this point whenever something goes wrong
and I've got my head in my hand she just
looks at me and goes it'll be good for
trigonometry girlfriend yeah all right
well thank you very much for being a
guest on the show well thank you for
being a guest on the show guys we'll see
in a week with another brilliant episode
with someone's reaction as what they're
talking about see you next week guys
take care thanks for watching guys as
always subscribe to the YouTube channel
click the bell button next to subscribe
button so you get notified when a video
comes out and follow us on all the
social media at trigger pod and also
leave us a nice review on iTunes
and spread the word